I cannot deliver the Mandate on which I
was elected by the conservative party
Liz truss resigned after just 45 days in
power becoming the shortest serving
prime minister of the UK by quite a
margin her plans to cut taxes roiled
financial markets and left her with the
lowest approval rating for a British
leader in decades we have taken decisive
action they crashed the economy working
working here's how her six weeks in
power unfolded and the reasons why her
Premiership Came Crashing Down so
quickly
it all started when Liz truss won the
leadership contest beating out other
candidates including former UK treasury
Chief Rishi sunak this trust is elected
as the leader of the conservative and
unionist party when she won the contest
she Strode onto the stage brimming with
confidence it would go on to Mark the
high point of her tenure
days later she got her first shock the
death of Queen Elizabeth II the
country's longest serving and much
beloved Monarch Queen Elizabeth II was
the rock on which modern Britain was
built mistrust made a moving speech at
the Queen's funeral days before she set
about installing her agenda and
delivering her promises from the elite
leadership campaign
I have three priorities for our economy
growth
growth and growth
and it's also when her political
problems began
mistrust and her Finance Minister
quasi-corting unveiled a far-reaching
series of economic reforms I can
announce today that we will cut the
basic rate of income tax to 19 pence in
April 2023 one year earlier within
minutes of Mr corteng's presentation the
markets responded
pound began dropping and yields on UK
government debt began to soar making the
cost of borrowing for the government
much more expensive
the plans soon Drew criticism from some
unusual quarters including the IMF which
criticized its fiscal stimulus at a time
when the bank of England was trying to
raise interest rates to stop inflation
it also Drew criticism from U.S
President Joe Biden well it's
predictable I mean it was I wasn't the
only one that thought it was a mistake
has the financial backlash deepened
against the plan and ordinary britons
were worried about higher mortgage
payments on their houses
it seemed the political pressure was
growing and the mood darkening King
Charles seemed to sum it up
anyway
in the days that followed things started
to unravel quickly
Trust basically fired her Chancellor
quasi quartain who was an old Ally and
replaced him with Jeremy Hunt within a
day he began pairing back her initial
ideas with a series of u-turns on the
tax cuts so it's a time when markets are
rightly demanding commitments to
sustainable public finances it is not
right to borrow to fund this tax cut
within three days her package had been
nearly entirely eviscerated
is this your last prime minister's
questions Miss truss who is seen as
headstrong was not about to quit even as
the chaos grew she turned up to
Parliament and vowed to fight on I am a
fighter and not a quitter
for Britain's mistrust will be
remembered as Liz the brief the shortest
serving prime minister in history she
will also be remembered as a symptom of
growing dysfunction within the Tory
party which is driven by divisions and
differing visions of how to take the
country forward
[Music]